[Musica]
i ghiacciai sembrano qualcosa molto
lontano da noi soprattutto da qui dal
cuore della pianura padana qualcosa che
la sulle alpi sull'himalaya sulle grandi
catene montuose nel nostro mondo va
avanti che ci interessiamo troppo di
loro ma se vi dicessi che i ragazzi di
oggi non potranno portare i loro figli a
vedere queste spettacoli della natura
che attirerebbero un po di più la vostra
attenzione
ebbene sì fra 50 anni i ghiacciai che
come esistono conosciamo ora non
esistono più saranno ridotti a piccole
placche di ghiaccio sulle cime più alte
difficilmente raggiungibile è anche
decisamente meno spettacolari saranno
localizzati appunto solo sulle cime più
alti e forse i nostri nipoti ci
chiederanno perché il monte bianco si
chiama così pur essendo grigio la prima
volta che sono andato sul ghiacciaio
ormai sono passati dieci anni gli aceri
fuori in alta valtellina uno dei più
grandi ghiacciai italiani
ecco oggi per percorrere la stessa per
arrivare lo studio samp signor
percorrere 250 metri di sentiero in più
e questo ritiro di soli in via c'è in
soli 10 anni 250 metri in più mai sono
numero un po strane se vi dicessi due
campi da calcio e mezzo nove campi da
pallacanestro
la prospettiva magari cambierebbe
e se avessimo la capacità di andare un
pochino più indietro nel tempo la
situazione sarebbe ancora più drammatica
nel 1989 anno in cui sono nato avremmo
dovuto percorrere addirittura sette
campi da calcio per aggiungere sullo
stesso ghiacciaio e inizio sta iniziando
a inizio novecento anno in cui più o
meno sono nati i miei nonni
avremmo dovuto percorrere addirittura 20
campi da calcio
in poco più di cento anni due chilometri
di valle che prima erano ricoperti da
ghiaccio
ora sono boschi sono praterie
tutto questo sotto i colpi nel
cambiamento climatico ghiacciai più
piccoli ghiacciai più frammentati
ghiacciai più grigi a tutti i detriti
che vi cadono sopra ma quanti sono
questi ghiacciai alpini che amiamo cene
conto di quanto stiamo parlando
abbiamo possiamo rispondere a questa
domanda grazie a un recente studio fatto
in collaborazione con alcuni scienziati
di paesi europei
mi piace alpini sono tanti 900 quasi 879
per la precisione ci sono gli accessi
tutte le alpi e l'italia ospita un
quinto di tutti i ghiacciai delle alpi
non sappiamo anche un piccolo apparato
sull'appennino un piacere del calderone
ormai in disfacimento questi ghiacciai
non sono più giganti che c'è giganti
sono pochi sono lì mi sono piccoli sono
rimasti piccoli limitati appunto a conca
esposti a nord che si proteggono dal
sole
questi ghiacciai coprono 325 chilometri
quadri
un dato che messo lì così magari non dà
un'idea ma se vi dicessi che coprono
un'area paragonabile più o meno a quella
del lago di garda
forse vi rendereste conto comunque
quanto essi siano importanti sulla
nostra italia
questi ghiacciai come vi dicevo stanno
arretrando in maniera molto
significativa in soli 60 anni hanno
perso circa il 50 per cento della loro
area 130 chilometri di quadri di
ghiaccio ora non ci sono più
ora sono fusi sono scesi lungo i fiumi
sono ritornati a mare sempre per avere
un'idea di quanto sia quanto stia
cambiando questa questa regola cia
lizzato in maniera un pochino più
tangibile 160 km he l'area del lago di
como in 60 anni abbiamo personale al
paragonabile a quella del lago di como
in ghiacciai i ghiacciai non si stanno
solo ritirando stanno cambiando la loro
pelle
noi vediamo ghiacciai più grigi
ghiacciai che si frammentano ghiacciai
più sporchi letteralmente e che cambiano
la loro il loro ciclo naturale delle
cose
abbiamo cercato di indagare un po questo
detrito che ormai copre i ghiacciai
diffusi in tutto il mondo
questa elettricità diverse origine una
locale pensate a tutto quel detrito
quelle rocce che cadono alle pareti
circostanti arrivano di sul ghiacciaio
ma una ben più importante ha un'origine
molto più lontano
un'origine che arriva da la nostra da
noi per merito nostro
la superficie dei ghiacciai non più
bianche appaiono grigi per colpa di
questo piccolissimi elementi abbiamo
raccolto il detrito abbiamo analizzato
portato il laboratorio abbiamo
identificato queste piccolissimi
elementi si chiamano cenno sfere sono
piccolissimi ripeto sono molto più
piccolo di un capello
ma da dove arrivano queste cielo schiere
queste cene sfere sono il prodotto della
combustione di idrocarburi e carbon
fossile in altri forni o comunque nelle
centrali termoelettriche colpa nostra
quindi queste piccole particelle vengono
prese in carico dalla circolazione
atmosferica arrivano sul ghiacciaio
precipitano rimangono intrappolate
all'interno del ghiaccio e precipita
sotto forma di neve questa neve diventa
ghiaccio rimangono intrappolati lì si
accumulano addirittura ecco questa forte
fusione glaciale in atto le libera ne
libera sul ghiacciaio dove appunto a noi
in una delle una strada di campagna e
abbiamo ritrovate poco male direste voi
tuttavia queste cene sfere queste
piccole particelle sono scure nere
sporcano il ghiacciaio l'importanza di
queste cene sfere è veramente alta per
la vita del ghiacciaio
perché se sono nere hanno la capacità di
assorbire in maniera molto molto
efficace il calore e trasferirlo quindi
al ghiacciaio l'india chelsea fonde e
quindi questo cenno sfere queste
particelle forza lo diciamo un destino
al ghiacciaio già in atto per propri
cambiamenti climatici
il concetto che fanno questa cena stava
pensate un po a un concetto di una
maglietta nera e una maglietta bianca
non metteremo mai d'estate una maglietta
nera perché essa si scalda molto più
velocemente di quella bianca e trasmette
questo calore ha ghiacciato sottostante
uno si una singola di queste cielo
schiere ovviamente non ha nessuna prende
effetto apprezzabile ma quando su queste
cena sfere sono miliardi che miliardi e
associate altri prodotti della
combustione come ceneri come può il air
in generale chiama the black carbon
hanno effetti apprezzabili sul
ghiacciaio e qui si innesca una sorta di
circolo vizioso ghiacciai più piccoli
fanno sì che l'energia dal sole riflessa
e molto molto minore
energia invece assorbita dal calore
molto più dalla terra è molto molto più
alto grazie ai più piccoli maggiore
energia assorbita dalla terra incremento
delle temperature e via di seguito
si innesca un circolo vizioso che non
c'entra in questo momento nulla con la
quantità di anidride carbonica molto
devastante per i ghiacciai lecce non
stele non sono l'unica firma umana sul
ghiacciaio noi magari pensiamo appunto
come ghiacciai questa cosa immacolata mi
ha fatto vedere che assolutamente non è
così ci sono altre firme della nostra
presenza come in tutti ormai comparti
ambientali sui ghiacciai abbiamo trovato
la radioattività di cernobyl
sicuramente non in concentrazioni
pericolose ma comunque presente è
identificabile
abbiamo trovato il ddt ormai bandito da
anni malisse accumulati e ora la fusione
la sta lasciando andare verso fiumi e
laghi ed eccetera
abbiamo trovato anche tutti quei
pesticidi e quelli erbicidi usati nelle
coltivazioni a valle che con lo stesso
meccanismo delle cielo sfere raggiungono
il ghiacciaio e lì si fermano
recentemente negli ultimi due anni
abbiamo identificato un elemento
antropico che volto un po di moda adesso
le dinamiche plastica
ecco campionario amico pasticche su un
ghiacciaio non è semplicissimo
pensate quando l'altro su un ghiacciaio
e tutto quello che avete addosso agli
scarponi e rampone che su di tecnici
sono composte fondamentalmente da fibre
di plastica
quindi per campionare questo è un
detrito secondo rigoroso metodo
scientifico è chiaro che non posso
andare vestiti così quindi abbiamo
trovato la soluzione al problema
arriviamo vicino al ghiacciaio ci
togliamo i scarponi i ramponi i
pantaloni cerchiamo di stare un po
nascosti magari indossando questo
bellissimo camice verde in cotone delle
comodissime soprattutto sicurissimi
zoccoli di legno ai piedi
iniziamo a campionare questo detrito in
vasetti di vetro anche questi molto
comuni soprattutto se dovete portali per
km nello zaino i risultati una volta
messa in gioco tutto questa questo
scenario portato ai campioni in
laboratori sono stati abbastanza
sorprendenti anti decisamente sopra
per ogni chilo di chi sa di detrito
raccolto abbiamo trovato 75 particelle
di micro plastica per avere un'idea una
concentrazione comparabile con quella
che troviamo sulle nostre spiagge magari
non quelle più inquinate ma comunque
sulle spiagge quindi evidentemente
situazioni decisamente più antropiche
decisamente più importanti l'effetto che
abbiano queste microplastiche sulle
comunità sugli organismi viventi
non è ancora chiaro la scienza ci stiamo
ancora lavorando tuttavia sicuramente
mangiare plastica non deve essere
prendono la parte piacevole
in questo contesto che come vedete tutto
i nostri effetti tutte le nostre
missioni che siano esse di particelle
che siano esse di gas hanno effetti su
questi ghiacciai psi ghiacciai sono dei
migliori archivi di questo periodo
chiamato antropocene tuttavia c'è
qualcuno che ci sta bene su questi
ghiacciai sicuramente se il nostro
rapporto con loro ha un po complesso ci
sono dei batteri perfettamente integrati
alla vita dei ghiacciai questi batteri
anche loro in questo periodo nella
disposizione un periodo attivo più lungo
estate un sonno invernale sotto la neve
molto più breve e vivono in queste sit
in queste depressioni piccole pressione
ghiacciaia chiamate che uniti dove
trovano sostanza organica per nutrirsi
ritrovano ossigeno e dove trova non
acqua l'acqua che la protegge dalla
radiazione solare questi batteri stanno
benissimo quindi e si moltiplicano si
moltiplicano producono sostanza organica
che sparsi sparano e sui ghiacciai
ghiacciai di oggi sono decisamente più
vivi di quel di cento anni fa
tuttavia anche questi piccoli battere
poverini senza colpe ovviamente hanno un
effetto molto importante su ghiacciaio
producono sostanza organica che
anch'essa è scura
anch'essa è nera e anch'essa ha una
funzione molto importante nella
assorbire l'energia solare trasmettere
al ghiaccio e fondere questo ghiaccio e
un altro circolo che si innesta perché
perché chiaramente il maggior fusione
vuol dire maggiore acqua maggior
disponibilità dei nutrienti e i batteri
stanno ancora stanno ancora meglio ma
quindi come scenari sembrano abbastanza
preoccupanti ma quindi cosa posso fare
io come ricercatori cosa puoi fare tu
per risolvere questo problema
la scienza da delle soluzioni per alcune
situazioni ci sono studi evidenti che
dimostrano come impacchettare gli acciai
con teli di plastica o altre fibre
funzioni funzioni davvero a preservare
la neve ghiaccio sottostante ghiacciare
vengono impacchettati a fine inverno e
vengono spacchettate iniziate
nell'inverno successivo oppure ci sono
studi che riconosce l'innevamento
artificiale quindi pagare neve coi
cannoni sul ghiacciaio abbia ovviamente
un effetto positivo funzionano questo
metodo di certo che funzionano ma
funzionano limitatamente innanzitutto a
delle aree dove la pratica dello sci
giustifica sia economicamente ma
soprattutto anche ambientalmente questi
interventi quindi la propria dire che
non c'è più nulla da fare che non
possiamo fare niente
ormai per prenderci cura di questi
ghiacciai che le aree sui ghiacciai
mezzo mondo vestito come un pazzo
diverbi con gli zoccoli ai piedi
oltre a rovinare la reputazione della
scienza italiana non serve a nulla per
salvare questi ghiacciai
forse no forse far vedere questa
immagine raccontarvi quello che vi ho
raccontato oggi come quello che ci
raccontano tantissimi studi e tantissimi
immagini questo tipo aumenta la
consapevolezza in noi fa sì che noi
tutti quando buttiamo una bottiglia in
plastica via magari nell'ambiente o
percorriamo qualche chilometro di troppo
con la nostra macchina
ci rendiamo conto che queste tutte le
azioni che compiamo andrà degli effetti
nell'ambiente e soprattutto apprezzabili
nei ghiacciai che sono poi gli elementi
più fragile dell'ambiente ma questo vuol
dire anche che ogni nostra piccola
azione positiva nel nostro piccolo gesto
per preservare l'ambiente ha effetti
molto molto importanti sulla
preservazione dell'ambiente di ghiacciai
in generale
forse purtroppo per i nostri ghiacciai
alpini così come conosciamo è troppo
tardi il dado è tratto
ma tuttavia che andati dobbiamo avere il
dovere morale di provarci affinché i
nostri nipoti possano vedere questi
incredibili spettacoli della natura
[Applauso]
[Musica]